[Music]
people have talked about how you can
sort of pop or crack most the bones in
your body that right can you find out if
I'd okay and now I have a special way I
popped my thumb stop it
wait wait wait yeah what's gonna happen
oh ah I don't think they could hear that
oh my god I am jealous if I had pants on
I'd do my hips but I don't want to do as
you can you pop something on me please
yeah yeah go wait go for how do I do
Oh Yoko why is it you can do that and I
can't wait here's the thumb oh wait
don't work oh wait would know why am i
doing molar oh oh okay oh god I love it
you know what I could be in Fifty Shades
of
yeah the periphrastic addition that was
painful and I've never been so excited
in my life
[Applause]
did ya that's okay I have three I don't
know this is the kind of show we have
you you studied opera you're such an
amazing so you studied opera at Oklahoma
City University and and you learn there
the key to opening up the voice and this
always intrigued me because when I watch
someone like you who can really sing it
feels otherworldly to me I don't know
how you can do it but you say that
there's a trick that you learn early on
which is called opening up the voice and
I don't even know what that is it's
basically you have to breathe it's it's
deep and low it's doing everything I say
tonight is sounds nasty but it's deep
and low and you have to breathe my voice
teachers you say breathe so deep it's
like you're breathing from your area you
know right lower stomach yes yes but
lower as low as you can
yes so you plant yourself plant your
feet relax your larynx your short short
little merry
[Laughter]
Andy and girls larynx
it's lengthening now okay oh so you just
breathe deep and low and like if I'm
singing something legit like a Puccini
you know it's like it's hard for me to
do sitting but see if you if you just
sit and breathe relax your throat and
your three nipples and basically use
this think deep and low from your yeah
down there
yeah I'm way down there now what don't
do that
people people tuning in late don't know
what you're talking about
larynx yeah
now Oh what it sounds like you're in a
little bit of pain
[Applause]
you really are a tenor though yeah well
who's to say who's the better singer
it's kinda like they can hear ya so it's
really yeah you can breathing deep and
low and I'm relaxing the lyrics yeah and
I'm letting it flow and and really and
truly there are all different kinds of
artists but for me that training helps
solidify eight shows a week any kind of
music I want to do I mean I'm not gonna
do rap you know that's not my thing
because it's my thing the worst thing
ever
yeah Brian and Kristin Chenoweth's are
rapping let's not watch it